vsauce kevin here and i want to go over
a real life math mistake that ended up
actually making a murderer our top story
tonight she seemed to be the woman with
everything a good job a lovely house and
the beginnings of a young family but
tonight the life of cheshire solicitor
sally clark is in tatters after she was
convicted of killing her two baby sons
two children both dead before their
first birthday sally clark the mother is
arrested charged
with murder
[Music]
what happens when two improbable
tragedies happen to the same person
how do you calculate odds to
differentiate unbelievably bad luck
from murder and
what happens when you make a conditional
probability error so severe
that it decimates countless lives i've
talked about a lot of paradoxes and math
problems that honestly are kind of
theoretical they're real but the
situations involving them don't come up
a whole lot you're not that likely to be
a game show contestant or have to figure
out whether you should go first in
russian roulette and it doesn't really
matter whether you can play a dot game
with perfect efficiency it's awesome to
know how it works and why but it's
ultimately not life or death
but
some math
is
life or death
on february 23 1998 sally and steve
clark were arrested and charged with
murder a month after their infant son
was found dead he was only two months
old sally and steve claimed that he had
died naturally a case of sudden infant
death syndrome also called crib death or
cot death that couldn't possibly have
been prevented the baby had physical
trauma including a cracked rib which his
parents claimed were from resuscitation
efforts so you can see why the police
would investigate the real problem the
thing that makes the case notable and
where the math comes in is that it
wasn't the first time one of the clark's
infants had been found
dead almost the exact same thing
happened with their first child about a
year earlier so
what are the odds that an incredibly
rare tragedy would happen twice in the
same family like the
horrible opposite of winning the lottery
more than once
and the major question is
what are the odds of that compared to
the odds that one or both of those
children
were murdered
well there was an expert for exactly
this sort of thing sir roy meadow was a
pediatrician who built a fantastic
reputation on his 1977 paper outlining
munchausen syndrome by proxy where a
caregiver secretly makes someone sick so
they're permanently dependent or
sometimes just to be seen as heroic and
selfless by making the sacrifice to care
for them by the early 1990s meadow had
become a recognized authority on child
abuse he
literally wrote the book on it the abcs
of child abuse and testified at dozens
of trials involving allegedly abusive
parents it's how we got meadow's law the
maxim sir roy used to summarize his
attitudes toward abuse cases one is a
tragedy two is suspicious and three is a
murder unless there is proof to the
contrary and
that's where we find our first red flag
he lifted his law from the james bond
villain goldfinger by now we've
discarded meadows law and sir roy
meadow's legacy is completely tarnished
because
he either didn't know conditional
probability or he didn't care and
sally clark paid the price here's how
conditional probability actually works
it's figuring out the chances of
something happening given that something
else has already occurred it's the
probability of a then b
sometimes that's a succession of totally
unrelated events like coin flips whether
i get a yes or a no on the second coin
flip doesn't depend on what i got the
first time
it's the odds of this times the odds of
that and we get a value for the chances
of both independent things happening
together despite neither one having
anything to do with the other let's take
cards the odds of drawing a heart are
one in four odds of drawing a second
heart 12 and 51 because we just took one
out of the deck two hearts in a row is
just one over four times twelve over
fifty-one which equals twelve in two
hundred four that's easy and
thinking that independent events somehow
influence each other when they don't
that's the famous gamblers fallacy and
you don't want to fall for that but
sometimes two events are related in some
way and figuring out the odds of both of
them happening together gets
trickier like the average chance of
getting into a car accident is around 1
in 350 for every 1 000 miles you drive
so what are the odds of getting into two
accidents in two months assuming you
drive one thousand miles a month do you
just do some multiplication for two
independent events one over 350 times
one over 350 to get one in 122 500
you could do that and that's an okay
place to start but what if you're the
worst driver in the world what if you've
only been driving for a couple of weeks
what if it's winter and everything is
icy is there a difference between
driving in los angeles and wyoming or
what if you're a fast and furious driver
and just had the unluckiest couple of
months of your life as the information
changes
the math changes
and this is all common sense so how did
roy meadow completely mess this up
during the trial meadow cited a report
that established the chances of an
infant dying from sudden infant death
syndrome using all sorts of different
risk factors like the mother being young
or being a smoker sally clark was a
healthy woman with a good standard of
living she was a lawyer so the chances
of someone in her circumstances
suffering a sids tragedy was calculated
at 1 in
8543 and this is where meadows math went
horribly wrong
he just multiplied one over
8543 by one over
8543 to get the chances of the two
independent events occurring twice for
the same mother which comes out to
1 in 73
million
given the united kingdom's birth rate
meadow said it's the sort of coincidence
that would happen once every century he
literally treated sally clark's deceased
children like playing cards or coin
flips instead of human beings living in
complex circumstances here's a question
what does 1 in 73 million
look like in 2014 tim urban created an
image with 1 million dots here's 73 of
those and as of 2021 only 19 of the 235
countries in the world have a population
over 73 million you could make an entire
documentary series out of all the
medical evidence to consider in this
trial but meadow's testimony reduced all
of the complexities into something the
court could easily understand
two accidents like this are so
statistically improbable that it makes
way more sense to think
she killed her kids
that type of faulty logic actually has a
name the prosecutor's fallacy which is
misusing statistics to create the
impression that the accused has to have
done the crime
sometimes that fallacy is used by
accident sometimes it's used on purpose
but in this case you can't even give
meadow the benefit of the doubt and say
he misspoke or just wasn't thinking
because he even compared the odds of
both clark children dying naturally to
someone betting successfully on 80 to 1
long shot horses for four races in a row
the problem is saying something only has
a 1 in 73 million chance of occurring
naturally suggests that it's way more
likely the explanation is simpler
sally clark
that meant being guilty of infanticide
what's truly weird to me about this
whole story is people don't always
assume the worst just because the odds
of something happening are crazy when
your grandma ethel hits a one in a
million jackpot on a casino slot machine
you think oh my god yay she is insanely
lucky we don't immediately suspect her
of being a cheater we think it's amazing
not utterly impossible
but we think about crimes differently
someone's been charged and the suspicion
is baked in
if you're a juror isn't one in 73
million way
way beyond a reasonable doubt beyond
defective math there was a lot going on
here like the clark's baby wearing an
apnea monitor that would go off if the
baby stopped breathing
that was standard practice after a
family suffered a sid's death in the
past the child's monitor kept going off
in the months prior to his death and
public health officials said the unit
was faulty and had it replaced did that
unit actually malfunction is there a
chance they misread
warning signs as we add layer upon layer
of complexity simple statistics are even
more appealing as a clean explanation
for a difficult problem it's not hard to
see that an entire trial's worth of
facts could boil down to one question is
it the one in 73 million chance that
sally clark was the unluckiest mother in
britain or one of the other
72 999
99999 outcomes and whether or not you're
misled by the implications of that
statistic makes all the difference
sally clark was convicted of murder by a
vote of 10 to 2 and she was given a
mandatory life sentence newspapers
reported that she was guilty of killing
her babies they called her baby killer
baby murderer and killer mom they
described her as a tortured soul her
husband steve insisted that she was
innocent her appeal was dismissed
because the court claimed the
statistical errors were quote incapable
of affecting the safety of the
convictions roy meadow backed them up
saying the time spent on an appeal was
quote wasted but the royal statistical
society blasted meadow and the court for
butchering such basic math
stating there is a real possibility that
without proper guidance and
well-informed presentation frequency
estimates presented in court could be
misinterpreted by the jury in ways that
are very prejudicial to defendants
society does not tolerate doctors making
serious clinical errors because it is
widely understood that such errors could
mean the difference between life and
death the case of rv sally clark is one
example of a medical expert witness
making a serious statistical error one
which may have had a profound effect on
the outcome of the case sally clark
appealed again not only was the
statistical evidence flawed but her
lawyers discovered medical documents
showing her son actually died from a
serious bacterial infection
the math was wrong and there was now a
rock-solid medical explanation for his
natural
death
five years after the trial analysis in
the journal pediatric and perinatal
epidemiology showed that as rare as
double sids is double infanticide is
even more rare making double sids
anywhere from four and a half to 9 times
more likely than double infant murder
sally clark was released in 2003 and
between the grief of losing two children
in tragic circumstances being wrongly
imprisoned for three years and having
the entire united kingdom think she was
the worst mother in the world
she died of alcohol poisoning just four
years later
she left behind her husband and their
third child
the fallout was a mens the british
general medical council removed roy
meadow from the british medical register
cases in which meadow testified were
revisited and the high court ruled that
expert witnesses were not immune to
disciplinary action he was barred from
being an expert witness endured a series
of hearings about professional
misconduct and by 2009 he was not
licensed to practice medicine roy meadow
should have known how basic probability
worked you know and i know so we should
expect a highly educated medical
professional willing to testify in court
to know too
but
he also blew it on the science his
misleading statistics dismissed the
possibility of any cause of death that
couldn't currently be identified like
an unknown genetic defect instead he
multiplied two fractions because
it was easy
and
most of the courtroom
bought it whether people think math is
boring or it's a waste of time to think
through theoretical concepts the fact is
we learn the theoretical so that we know
how to solve problems in reality and
sometimes to avoid terrible tragedies
it's why we have to understand look
there's an old conditional probability
joke about a statistician who said that
he always flies with a bomb in his
suitcase when someone incredulously
asked him why he said because the odds
of two people having bombs on the same
flight are astronomical
if you get that joke you get conditional
probability and
if that courtroom knew how it worked
sally clark would probably be alive
today
and as always
thanks for watching
today is not a
victory we are not victorious there are
no winners here
we have all lost
we simply feel relief that our nightmare
is finally at an end
[Music]
you